a court in South Africa has blocked
strike action by minibus taxi drivers in
Cape Town at least three people have
been killed during increasingly violent
protests the walkout has disrupted
transport and affected schools and
Health Services
joins us live from Cape Town now and
Familia can you just tell us a little
bit more about this court decision to
block drivers from striking
well that Court decision came after the
City of Cape Town along with a bus
company applied to the court to have the
strike stopped which the premier of the
Western Cape has said has been important
in terms of trying to prevent any
further arrests it's likely to give the
city more powers to arrest people
allegedly responsible for some of the
violence we've seen in recent days where
roads have been blocked and vehicles
have been prevented from passing by or
traveling through the city where they've
also been reportedly some instances of
looting and that's also according to the
premier's office and the impact that the
strike has had on the city is that
because police resources have had to
focus on the strikes specifically at
least 1 500 police officers deployed to
deal with that there's now a lag in
terms of services in other areas and
they've said this is why that looting
occurred now the city has also said that
as you may mentioned the education and
health care services have also been
impacted and we see that in a place like
this bus depot that usually would be far
busier but because of the strike and the
intimidation and harassment that's what
the city calls it they've also gone on
to call it thuggery because of that
violence operations like this which
would normally be an alternative means
of Transport have been limited so
essentially at this point the greatest
impact really on commuters in Cape Town
where does this leave things in regards
to negotiations between the city and the
bus company
thank you
well the city has so far said that it
would not continue negotiations if the
violence didn't stop and we've seen a
quiet today today so far compared to the
last few days whereas that mentioned
there'd been roads blockaded and also a
bus depot set to light and we know that
three people have been killed in that
violence so the city has been adamant
that it won't continue these
negotiations if the violence didn't end
we have seen uh Lal now at least to some
extent to come restored and so uh
santaco the taxi organization has said
that it expects to continue talks with
the city at some point today and may be
making an announcement later in the day
and we could be looking at the
resumption of those taxi operations
perhaps today or tomorrow and that's if
those talks go well but the city has
been very adamant in that saying that
taxi operators need to abide by the law
taxi drivers have complained that their
vehicles have been impounded and it
seems like a simple issue in that they
should by the law by traffic regulations
but it has really escalated into uh into
a disagreement where we've seen a
significant amount of violence and again
the city has said has been used to
intimidate them centako on the other
hand saying that its members not
responsible but also calling for calm
okay thank you so much that is for me to
Miller for us in Cape Town